vous annoncez hier par la voix du
président qui me dit et il faudrait pour
ce parc le flanc de joie ça fait 4 plus
de moi qu'à dernière annonce alors
apparaissent disparaissent proviennent
partent en fait vous ne pensez pas un
mot vous dit une chose et vous faites le
contraire et vous vous moquez du monde
[Musique]
pas de mise à disposition des masques
ffp2 rien pour accélérer la campagne de
vaccination et vous continuez à refuser
au nom de johnson & johnson & johnson le
vaccin russe qui lui a pas de nom il
s'appelle smic comme le premier
satellite et j'ai vu que monsieur ciotti
disait comme doit dorénavant l'idéologie
dans la crise sanitaire c'est de
l'obscurantisme et rien d'autre
[Musique]
vous nous aviez promis de vacciner matin
midi et soir mais malheureusement ce
n'est pas ce que vous faites
quelques heures avant les annonces
présidentielles
le préfet de police de paris annoncé une
baisse de 25% du nombre de vaccins
disponibles dans la capitale la semaine
[Musique]
avez vous suffisamment protégé nos
enseignants non avez vous recruté du
personnel pour remplacer les absences
inévitable en temps de pandémie non
avez vous mis en place des classes
allégé pour éviter le développement des
foyers épidémiques
non avez vous testé largement pour
éviter la propagation du virus non avez
vous équiper les établissements de
purificateurs d'air non
[Musique]